Netflix is heating up this June with an exciting
slate of new releases.
From new seasons of fan favorites to pulse-pounding
original films, here are the best new Netflix
releases to add to your queue in June 2019.
We're kicking off the month with one of the
most hotly anticipated returns of the year.
Black Mirror is storming onto Netflix, and
the episode lineup looks just as crazy as
the past installments.
Thanks to a series of trailers for the upcoming
fifth season, we have an idea of what each
of the three new episodes will entail.
In "Rachel, Jack and Ashley too," a lonely
girl finally gets the chance to meet her favorite
singer via a toy called an "Ashley Too," only
things get dark when the toy appears to channel
more than the pop star's personality.
In "Striking Vipers," a chance encounter kicks
off a string of events that soon spiral out
of control.
And in "Smithereens," an unbalanced cab driver
goes on the ride of his life.
The whole season drops on June 5th.
The early days of Netflix originals were filled
with now-iconic titles, but one show stood
out prominently enough to reach cult classic
status: 3%, the Brazilian dystopian thriller
you never knew you were missing until you
watched it.
The first season of 3% introduced the premise
of a population of young adults who have to
compete against each other in a cutthroat
competition called The Process.
Only three percent of participants make it
through and get the chance to live beyond
famine and poverty.
We can't get into the details of the rest
of the season or its follow-up without spoiling
all the twists, so suffice it to say that
3% is binge TV at its finest.
Check it out when the third season drops on
June 7th.
Cooking and travel shows are a dime a dozen,
but Netflix's upcoming original The Chef Show
deserves a special mention, mainly for the
people involved.
The series sees Iron Man director Jon Favreau
stepping in as producer, director, and star,
alongside chef Roy Choi.
It's basically Jon Favreau cooking things
and talking about food, which is fine all
by itself, but the trailer also showcases
some instantly familiar faces.
Yup, it looks like half the stars of the MCU
stopped by, with Robert Downey, Jr., Tom Holland,
Gwyneth Paltrow, and even Kevin Feige and
the Russo brothers sit down for a meal.
If Jon Favreau in an apron looks familiar,
that's because the concept for the show came
out of his own 2014 film Chef, for which Roy
Choi taught him how to cook.
As Favreau explained:
"During the production of Chef, I developed
a much deeper understanding of the ways in
which we express our emotions, share our cultures,
and seek meaningful connections through the
act of cooking and eating."
The kitchen is my domain, that was our deal
… I don't give a f--- what the deal was."
If that sounds like something in your wheelhouse,
be sure to tune in on June 7th when The Chef
Show starts cooking.
Netflix has been killing it with their original
sci-fi thrillers, and now I Am Mother is set
to continue that trend.
Starring Oscar-winner Hilary Swank and young
actress Clara Rugaard, I Am Mother is set
in the future and follows a young girl who's
raised by a robot named Mother in an underground
vault.
From birth, she's taught that the outside
world is an uninhabitable wasteland.
But the appearance of a woman from the outside
throws that narrative into question.
In an exclusive interview, director Grant
Sputore explained that while the film explores
our relationship with the high-tech future
we're creating, the thematic elements go even
deeper.
"For me, what it's really about is the discussion
of what it means to be a good person.
How do you work out right from wrong, how
do you work out who you are, separate to what
your parents want you to be?"
Basically, get ready for a mind-bending adventure
when I Am Mother premieres on June 7.
Music lovers will get a trip down memory lane
on June 12th with Rolling Thunder Revue: A
Bob Dylan Story by Martin Scorsese.
With this upcoming documentary, the acclaimed
filmmaker is taking viewers on a musical odyssey
into The Rolling Thunder Revue tour, which
saw Dylan crossing the country to play in
smaller, more intimate venues in an attempt
to get back to his roots -- and his fans.
And with Martin Scorsese at the helm, there's
no telling what to expect.
Bob Dylan may be the perfect subject for a
filmmaker who loves to put a little crazy
in his films.
Turn it up when Rolling Thunder Revue: A Bob
Dylan Story drops on June 12th.
Adam Sandler's films are a little like a blind
gunman shooting at a running horse.
There are plenty of misses, but every now
and then one of those bullets is bound to
hit meat.
Murder Mystery looks like it just might be
a bullseye.
Co-starring Jennifer Aniston, Murder Mystery
follows a New York couple who take a second
honeymoon to Europe and get embroiled in the
murder of a billionaire on his private yacht.
Soon, they're the prime suspects in the crime,
and they have to go on a hilarious, action-packed
quest to prove their innocence...and maybe
find the true murderer in the process.
Buckle up for the ride.
Murder Mystery premieres on June 14th.
Anthony Anderson headlines Beats as a former
music producer who's gone through some rough
times and has ended up working as a security
guard at a Chicago school.
There, he meets a troubled young student with
a gift for music, and together the two may
just find a way to triumph over their pasts.
Beats looks like a heartwarming, inspirational
drama that won't pull any punches.
Take a look when Beats arrives on June 19th.
True crime is apparently a big hit for Netflix,
and that's a win-win for fans of the genre,
too, because there's no shortage of true crime
docs to binge on the streaming service.
On top of explosive hits like Making a Murderer,
Netflix recently introduced The Confession
Tapes, which as of Season 1 is sitting with
a 100% rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
The show focuses on confessed criminals who
later claimed that they'd been coerced into
giving their confessions.
This show takes a deep dive into the shocking
crimes and explores how the original confessions
may have changed everything.
Season 2 arrives on June 21st, perfectly timed
for an early binge to kick off the summer.
If you like dark dramas that have a tendency
to blow your mind, you'll love Dark.
Part thriller, part sci-fi, and part supernatural,
Dark follows three separate generations as
they all work to find missing children.
The first season of this German series premiered
on Netflix to rave reviews, yet still remains
something of a hidden gem on the streaming
service.
If you haven't caught the first season yet,
do yourself a favor and add it to your queue.
You can watch it in its original German with
subtitles, or the English dubbed version if
you prefer, but definitely give it a shot
either way.
Now that Season 2 is on its way on June 21st,
there's never been a better time to discover
this fantastic series.
For two seasons, Netflix's documentary series
Dope has offered an unprecedented street-level
look into the American drug war, focusing
on the lives and crimes of the people on both
sides of the ongoing conflict.
From task forces raiding homes and production
facilities to the dangers smugglers face on
a day-to-day basis, Dope have given viewers
an uncompromising glimpse into what it's really
like in this dangerously topsy turvy world.
Drugs, guns, and cash are set to take center
stage for a third season of the highly rated
docuseries, which premieres on June 28th.
Even though all of Netflix's Marvel shows
have officially been canned, there's still
one final season to look forward to.
Marvel's Jessica Jones has followed the titular
heroine through a whirlwind two seasons that
saw her taking on the villainous puppetmaster
Kilgrave and then kind of taking on her best
friend Trish.
Where will Season 3 take us?
Netflix so far hasn't given a solid release
date for the third season of Jessica Jones,
so keep your eyes peeled for it to show up.
Those are all the Netflix originals we're
getting excited about.
Now here are the rest of the hot new titles
coming to Netflix in June 2019.
Curiously enough, Netflix's best new action
releases are all animated.
Sure, we've got Batman Begins and The Dark
Knight joining the service in June, but those
films seem to come and go pretty often.
More exciting, of course, is the addition
of Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse, which
is nothing short of a 117-minute hurricane
of pure fun.
"Act super normal, selecting a bagel … Spiderman?
… You know that's funny, I get that a lot."
That's dropping later in the month, on June
26th, and just a bit earlier, on June 21st,
comes another surprise the entire run of Neon
Genesis Evangelion and two full-length Evangelion
films
Interested in thrills?
On June 1st, look for Carrie...although since
there's no date attached, it's unclear if
it's going to be the original 1976 version
or the 2013 remake.
Just gonna have to roll the dice on this one.
“Don't be in such a hurry...I'm hurrinhawaeffumyou,
ya know that?"
On June 16th, look for Cop Car, a silly sounding
film that's actually a suspenseful, well-made
low-budget thriller starring Kevin Bacon as
a no-good cop hunting down two kids who steal
his car.
“Ha.”
There's a big load of drama dropping on June
1st, including a few classics that never get
old.
Keep your eyes peeled for Platoon, as well
as Network, a 1976 satire about the news media
industry that pulled in four Oscar wins.
What else?
50/50 is an understated dramedy starring Seth
Rogen and Joseph Gordon-Levitt, and The Space
Between Us stars Asa Butterfield as a boy
on Mars who comes back to Earth and learns
about being human.
Finally, Gran Torino is also popping in on
the first to remind you to stay off Clint
Eastwood's lawn.
"Get off my lawn."
We're also looking at a smattering of new
TV seasons crossing into the Netflix jungle
in June.
On the first of the month, check out the second
season of Dynasty.
On the 3rd, you can binge Documentary Now!:
Season 3, which is bringing in a whole new
cast of guest stars for its ridiculous mockumentary
narratives.
Finally, keep your eyes peeled for Season
3 of Shooter on the 21st.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.